So we're on the home stretch now
The last thing I want to talk about those can have it a little bit more sizable was programming subsystems
Obviously as your game begins to grow it increases the chance that you may want to go
Editing some of the engine source code. All right, the source code is freely available
Debugging symbols are available
You can go to the github and download the source build version in the engine if you want to customize that engine
Or something I would encourage you to think about first for both portability and several advantages really is subsystems
So subsystems are essentially automatically instance classes of various
Sections of the engine they have managed lifetimes meaning you don't have to control when they come in when they go out
They're inherently linked to a particular part of the engine and they share the lifetime of that part of the engine
This helps us get around overriding engine classes, which can reduce compile times
It can keep things more modular and portable and more easy to share sections between different projects
And it exposes access to fun of new functionality to blueprint and Python
And so some examples of typical subsystems that you might want to inherit from our engine subsystem
And it's subsystem game instance and local player
There's also world and really a host of others where we've already talked about the enhanced the local player enhanced input subsystem
So, yeah, there's a lot of these if you look up subsystem you'll find them
But these are the key classes that you would typically want to possibly expand upon
So just talking a little bit about the lifetimes
Some of this is maybe gonna be a little bit obvious
but it's worth just mentioning anyway, like we said the lifetime that each of these subsystems has will be shared by the
The engine system that they are attached to so for an engine subsystem
They are initialized when the engine module gets its startup function called and
De-initialized when the engine module get its shutdown function called and it can be accessed through G engine in C++
Editor subsystems similar. It's when the editor module gets its startup and shutdown called and can be accessed through G editor
Game instance subsystem we talked about the game instance flow earlier in the in the talk
so it's initialized when the game instance is initialized and
De-initialized when the game instance is shut down and you can access that through C++ at least
By grabbing a reference to the game instance
So most objects most you objects in the game have access to the game instance because it's something that exists kind of above all of
Them I'll show an example of that on the next slide. And then last of all, we have the local player subsystem
so these are initialized and de-initialized as the local player is created and destroyed that may not necessarily be at the beginning of your
At the beginning of your game depending on if you dynamically create new players part way through your game process
And there is a local player subsystem for each player
So this is kind of like somewhat distinct from rest of these it would only have one for each of these there will be
there will be a subsystem for each local player and
each of these subsystems can be accessed in the same way through getting a reference to that local player in C++ and then
That can be from the player controller and then through that you would access that subsystem
So just in terms of actually performing that accessing that was all the C++
Here's an example of how that might look in C++
So if we wanted to get a game instance if we just made a my game instance subsystem
Which inherits from game instance subsystem we would get our reference to the game instance
normally, you can just call this function get game instance and then you just do get subsystem and this is a
Generic type so that just casts it for you into the into the type that you need
But in terms of accessing it through blueprint, it's actually quite a bit easier and every time you make a subsystem
It'll automatically get added into this list
So if you just look look up subsystems these options will kind of like populate through what's available
And then accessing it would just look like this again
We've already seen an example of this through the enhanced input local player subsystem
And then the last thing really to touch on is that like we said this is available through Python
Through just unreal dot get engine subsystem or get editor subsystem, etc
And then you just provide the type of subsystem that you're looking for worth mentioning that that Python is in development
It's still quite an experimental feature
But just worth highlighting that one of the advantages of making these subsystems in the first place is it does expose it to Python
If that's something you want to try using
Okay, so home stretch. This is the last content slide
but just something that's worth mentioning is that when you're coding these things obviously with
Video games a lot of time we might be reusing things that other people have solved before
Engines in general so solve some of those problems for us
But it's just worth pointing out that there's a kind of suite of function libraries available to us
That will do some of the things that you might be wanting to do already, right?
Some of this a lot of these are actually exposed to blueprint
So any of these you kismet system kismet math kismet is the old name for blueprint
So kismet system library kismet math library you gameplay statics
These are all function libraries that are exposed to blueprints
FMath is only for native. Although a lot of that is actually getting used through the kismet math library
And so but they're not exclusively for use in blueprint
So you can also access these through C++ and they are essentially libraries of static functions
So it's very easy through C++ to just do you kismet system library colon colon and then use one of the functions on it
It's also you can kind of just give an example of these actually being used if we just go into our level blueprint
And we just did something like spawn actor from class
That is a that's custom
But we just talked before about the save game to slot didn't we and then if we hover over this you can see this
Comes from gameplay statics, which is one of the ones we're talking about here
normally if you want to see where a
If you want to kind of look at a little bit more and you just don't kind of want to jump from some code from some
Blueprint into code you can double click and as long as your ID is set up
Okay, it will actually jump to that point in code, but I tested this before
It's not working for me
But normally this would take us into the gameplay statics class and straight to that function just you can kind of browse around and see
Exactly what it's doing
and
Yeah, the last thing that I want to mention is just that you can actually make some of these libraries yourselves
So these ones are the ones that are available to you off the bat and they do a lot of things for you
the F math one is useful just a lot of things you typically need to do with mathematical functions things like ABS or max or
Min or lerping and things like this, but you can also make and expose your own blueprint function libraries
So all you have to do is make a class that inherits from you blueprint function library and then make the functions on its static
And as long as they are you you do need this same markup above them with the you function blueprint callable
And that will expose it to C++ to blueprints. It is also worth mentioning that
Blueprint function libraries are encouraged for a number of different reasons
but actually the same is true really of
Anytime you make a static function on any you object and have that you function blueprint callable
Metadata above it. It will actually be exposed to your game. So just as an example with our exploding barrel
from last session
if I just put a
Static function here some static function from my barrel and put you function mark up above it and make it blueprint callable. Even that is
Accessible from
some function
even that is accessible from
Blueprint and you can see that the class is calling on as an exploding barrel
So I might have given you some power that you you're going to abuse there
But just kind of worth highlighting and that you can create these things yourself
and it gives you a lot of ability to expose functionality to designers that they may not necessarily have the
programming capability to do themselves
okay, and I think
That brings us to the end
We covered this in the last session
But just to kind of resources and support available to you the unreal engine and documentation always incredibly useful
Unreal engine YouTube that we have spotlights. There's updates about new features
There's live chats and stuff there a lot of those streams go through to YouTube
But they do originate from the the twitch and then we've got the unreal developer network for licensees where you actually get support from epic
staff
Unreal answer hub is amazing very vibrant community from unreal developers
If you aren't a licensee and you get a lot of pretty quick answers there
And then the unreal engine community wiki has lots of amazing tutorials and documentation as well
So for any of this stuff, you can kind of follow up and go into more detail there
Thanks very much for watching